ici on aura dans la viseur de production
bienvenue chez robert alexis traiteur en
fait on a deux cuisines et si on avait
le département des cocktails et boucher
évidemment là en ce moment c'est vide
les carnets de commandes sont anémiques
la majorité des employés licenciés
le traiteur s'est lancé dans les plats
surgelés pour survivre non mais loin de
tout à fait habituelle et nos activités
habituelles pourrait comprendre des
milliers des dizaines de milliers de
deux plats on prête à manger pour
combler des événements de 1000 1500
personnes
oui bonjour steeve côté et planificateur
d'événements que flux servirait de bap
trouver des solutions devenu malgré lui
spécialiste des congrès virtuel il a vu
un progrès dans l'utilisation du web par
les entreprises
on est capable de faire du team building
on est capable d'aller plus que juste le
simple chat pour poser nos questions
chez ce locataire de mobilier
événementiel on a lancé une offensive
marketing le zéro risque pour se
démarquer
on va faire une désinfection du mobilier
au complet on vole emballé correctement
on va l'amener à l'entrepôt on va
s'assurer qu'il est en bonne état puis
on voit le ressortir sur le prochain
événement leur nettoyer encore dx
mobilier a perdu 95 % de ses revenus
avec la pandémie est fermé sa succursale
d'ottawa
elle salue l'aide gouvernementale mais
souhaiterait plus de subventions et
moins de près on va seulement 5 des
entreprises des fournisseurs qui sont
endettés
c'est par dessus la tête qui vont de la
misère à sortir du lot mais tout n'est
pas noir noël s'en vient les parts et de
bureaux seront virtuel que ce soit des
spectacles ça soit des quizz qui eiffel
sur la plateforme on a vu des photos
doute on voit des dj live on peut parler
de chaque fois des demandes spéciales
on ne pensait à trois menus donc chaque
client de chaque convive du parti
virtuel pourrait pourrait manger leur
repas chacun à la maison des repas
individuel livré en même temps à 200 400
personnes un défi que l'entreprise ne
pensais jamais avoir à relever ici marie
josée paquet comme radio canada montréal